Ok. À xin chào cả nhà. Hiện tại là cũng
đã 5:5 rồi [âm nhạc] và
không biết là hiện mọi người đã có nghe
Minh nói rõ không ạ? Nếu mà nghe rõ thì
mọi người cho Minh số một. Wow!
Ok rồi.
Ngày hôm qua buổi tối [âm nhạc] Minh có
share cái thông tin là sáng nay mình sẽ
zoom. À nói chung là đây là một cái
thông báo nó hơi buồn. Mình nghĩ vậy
[âm nhạc] cho nên cũng làm cho một số
anh chị bị miss cái thông tin này hoặc
là họ cũng có một số anh chị cũng chưa
kịp sắp xếp lịch đó [âm nhạc] mọi người.
Tuy nhiên mình cứ lên chương trình thôi
và anh chị nào có thể tham dự cùng mình
buổi sáng hôm nay coi như [âm nhạc] nó
cũng một phần
gọi là duyên đi hết cả nhà. Còn
được bao nhiêu mình tính bấy nhiêu
để không [âm nhạc] phải để cho mọi người
chờ lâu thì mình xin phép được bắt đầu.
Đầu tiên á là hôm nay chúng ta sẽ nói về
cái [âm nhạc] trợ lý. Trợ lý là từ gi
cái bài hôm trước là chúng ta đã đi qua
là cái buổi mà trợ lý tạo trợ lý từ
[âm nhạc] chatbot à trên. Sau đó ở đầu
buổi ba đó mình có nói thêm do là cái
buổi [âm nhạc] hai bị gián đoạn bởi cái
máy tính của mình. Vậy thì hôm trước á
mọi người bắt đầu hình dung ra là
chatbot là cách làm thôi và cách đưa cái
bộ Megafm.
Xin phép mở cái [âm nhạc]
Megaf trước để mọi người hình dung.
Mọi người đợi mình một xíu thôi.
Mục đích của ba buổi vừa rồi á là mình
sẽ đi liên tục nha mọi người. Ví dụ
notebook nó sẽ làm được cái gì? Sau đó
nó link dữ liệu giữa notebook [âm nhạc]
và nó như thế nào. Được không cả nhà? Và
trong germin có những cái cuốn sổ tay,
cuốn sổ ghi chú. Rồi trong đó sẽ có phần
chatbot được không ạ? Đó là buổi hai. Và
qua buổi ba chúng ta sẽ có là thêm một
buổi là nói về tự động hóa ở trong đó là
dùng cái công cụ antiravity. Nhưng làm
sao [âm nhạc] để chúng ta lưng được ừ
cái ý tưởng ví dụ như cái việc mà chúng
ta làm đỡ phải bị rối trong cái việc là
ngay ban đầu cái mục tiêu chính mình là
cái gì ạ? Không dùng quá nhiều công cụ
AI để
chúng ta đỡ bị rối, đỡ bị mệt đầu. Mà tự
nhiên bây giờ ông Minh [âm nhạc] ổng lại
chia sẻ thêm công cụ A, công cụ B ví dụ
vậy. Thì ở đây thực ra là nó đều có một
mục đích đó cả nhà. Mình đi từ công cụ
Gerai rồi lại đi qua công cụ Anti
Gravity. Và đến thời điểm hiện tại Minh
vẫn đang đi với mọi người là công cụ
Anti Gravity nằm trong hệ sinh thái của
Google mà thôi. Được không cả nhà? Nằm
trong hệ sinh thái của Google cùng một
tài [âm nhạc] khoản đây. Gmail đó. Cùng
một tài khoản Gmail. Vậy thì lúc này cái
[âm nhạc] tính chất mà liên quan của nó
như thế nào thì Minh sẽ hôm nay sẽ đi
với mọi người cái chỗ Megaf Minh đưa vào
cái công cụ Anti Gravity
thì nó sẽ hoạt [âm nhạc] động như thế
nào, nó tối ưu hơn bên chat GPT hay
không thì mọi người cùng xem qua nhé.
A nó sẽ tối ưu hơn bên nền tảng Zina hay
không. Đây [âm nhạc] mình sẽ share lại
màn hình.
Nãy là mọi người đang nhìn thấy cái màn
hình nào mình sorry. Hồi nãy mọi người
đang nhìn thấy cái màn hình chưa có câu
lệnh Megaf đúng không ạ?
>> Đúng không ơi?
>> Còn lúc nãy là do mình share hai màn
hình
cho nên mọi người sẽ không thấy được cái
màn hình nội dung bên [âm nhạc] trong
của câu Megaf này. Giai đoạn một nè,
giai đoạn hai, giai [âm nhạc] đoạn 3 rồi
contact.
Cái chữ viết tắt này là CRT này là để
giao vai trò đó mọi người. Giao vai
[âm nhạc] trò cũng như là bối cảnh, ngữ
cảnh và hành động ở bên trong của cái
Mega Firm. Đó. Rồi [âm nhạc] vậy thì bây
giờ mình sẽ đi qua đến cái đoạn là mình
sẽ đưa cái công cụ này.
Ok. Vậy thì bây giờ nhé mình sẽ đi với
nhau đến cái công cụ là Anti Gravity.
Hôm trước mình có gửi một cái đoạn clip
ngắn là cách cài Anti [âm nhạc] Gravity.
Mọi người cũng đã xem qua đúng không ạ?
Cách cài Anti Gravity.
bản 2.0 nha mọi người. Hiện nay chúng ta
là người mới và Minh xác định luôn là
chúng ta mọi người ngồi cùng nhau ở đây
là [âm nhạc] mọi người là cùng là người
mới nói về công cụ này. Cho nên chúng ta
sẽ đi thống nhất với nhau là dùng cái
công cụ Anti Raavity 2.0. Hôm trước anh
chị nào chưa cài [âm nhạc] đặt, chưa
dùng á thì có thể xem lại cái đoạn video
mà Minh gửi trên nhóm đó. Hướng dẫn về
cách cài đặt anti Gravity [âm nhạc] 2.0
cũng khá là đơn giản. Thì giao diện nó
về cơ bản là như thế này nhé. Mình
[âm nhạc] sẽ nhắc nhanh thôi. Nó gần
giống với chat GPT. Ờ cái cửa sổ bên tay
[âm nhạc] trái nó là cái history đó. Và
những cái conversation mà chúng ta đã
làm việc với [âm nhạc] AI này được không
cả nhà? Rồi vậy thì
khi mà cái bộ Mega Firm lúc nãy á mình
[âm nhạc] có nếu mình tạo chatbot thì nó
sẽ ra một cái giao diện mà như mọi người
vẫn thấy là chỉ cần click vào đường link
chatbot [âm nhạc] rồi chúng ta gõ câu
lệnh. Còn với trường hợp này, với cái
câu lệnh mà mình đang có này. Đây với
cái câu lệnh này thì mình nó sẽ hoạt
động ở đây trên đây như thế nào? Mình sẽ
mở ra [âm nhạc] luôn cái đây. Hiện nay
nó chỉ là một tập tin thôi nha mọi
người. Bản chất nóở đây là một tập tin
thôi. Một tập tin giống một cái file văn
bản, file Word, file Excel vậy thôi. Và
mọi người hình dung ra trên [âm nhạc] AI
chúng ta sẽ làm việc với nhau là chủ yếu
là tập tin gọi là MDO. Chữ MD. Thì nội
dung này được đóng gói trong một file MC
down. Rồi mình sẽ để cái đường dẫn này
vào đây.
[hắng giọng]
Đó thì ở đây mình sẽ copy luôn nguyên
cái đường dẫn à mình đang [âm nhạc] có
và từ cái tên của cái MegaFm đưa vào
[âm nhạc] đây luôn. đường dẫn như thế
nào mình để nguyên rồi chọn mình chọn
lại model tí xíu rồi
này thực thi ok chỗ này thay [âm nhạc]
vì bây giờ mình ghi là hẻ thực thi thì
cho tôi
biết nội dung này
b gì thì mình sẽ hỏi nó cho tôi biết cái
[âm nhạc] nội dung này đang nói gì rồi
mình sẽ đi tiếp với mọi người ha để cho
mọi người hình dung được ở trong này nó
làm việc như thế nào với cái file này.
Rồi trong cái quá trình mà nó đang liệt
kê cái này, chờ nó liệt kê ra thì
[âm nhạc] mọi người cho Minh một vài
thông tin như sau. Ở đây chúng ta hiện
nay có khoảng gần 30 người. Vậy thì
chúng ta mong muốn tạo ra chatbot gì?
Mọi người cho Minh một vài [âm nhạc]
cảnh tay, một vài thông tin được không
ạ? Ví dụ như kế toán, tài chính, kinh
doanh, nghiên cứu thị trường hay là
[âm nhạc] viết content hay cái gì đó.
Mọi người cho Minh một vài thông tin mọi
người. Ví dụ muốn tạo chckpot loại gì?
kế toán tài chính. Kế toán tài chính
nhưng cụ thể hơn được không ạ? Ví dụ như
là
nghiên cứu hay là làm cái gì đó thu thập
thông tin trên web
giáo viên tiếng Anh.
sắp xếp kế hoạch sản xuất.
Ok. À bây giờ ở đây là mình sẽ [âm nhạc]
lấy tạo chbot bóc khối lượng vừa trên
bản vẽ xây dựng được không ạ? Về cơ bản
là được nhá. Mình chỉ mình sẽ mình sẽ
ngồi quan trọng là mình sẽ làm việc với
AI này là [âm nhạc] mình sẽ đi dần từng
bước cho mọi người thấy à cấp nó làm như
thế nào nhé. Chbot bóc khối lượng. Đây
cũng là một cái
mình sẽ copy đúng cái nội dung [âm nhạc]
của bạn Vân Anh nhé. Bóc khối lượng dựa
trên bản vẽ xây dựng. Sau đó mình sẽ đi
đến là sắp xếp kế hoạch sản xuất và
một cái chatbot khác đó là nghiên cứu
thông tin của một bạn nữa là phân tích
dữ liệu biên phiên dịch. Biên phiên dịch
tiếng gì không thể để tính tiếng.
Ok. Rồi mình quay lại cái chỗ [âm nhạc]
đoạn này. Vậy thì ở đây nó có nói nè đây
là một system ROM SH from hướng dẫn dùng
để biến AI thành [âm nhạc] một kiến trúc
sư from chuyên nghiệp khi nội dung này
vào chat ha rồi là chat user hay là chat
VPT [âm nhạc] vân vân AI sẽ hoạt động
như một công cụ tạo from. Mục đích của
việc này là tạo ra một cái mẫu form thay
vì chúng ta bình thường không biết cách
tạo mẫu form làm sao cho nó chuẩn
[âm nhạc] chỉnh hay là nó rõ ràng. có
đầy đủ ngữ cảnh, có vai trò, có các thứ
vân [âm nhạc] vân thì ở đây nó sẽ làm
cái việc đó được không cả nhà? Đó, thay
vì hồi nãy bên kia mình yêu cầu nó đọc
thì bây giờ ở đây mình kêu nó tóm tắt
lại và nó cho mình biết ở trong đây
[âm nhạc] có cái gì thì nó cho mình biết
đây nội dung bên trong và nó cho mình
biết luôn là cách dùng thực tế là
[âm nhạc] chỉ cần copy paste cái nội
dung này vào sau đó là tôi confirm
[âm nhạc] để làm cái gì đây? Đây tôi cần
firm để làm cái nhiệm vụ X. AI sẽ tự
động đi qua sáu giai đoạn là xuất ra ba
[âm nhạc] phiên bản khác nhau được không
cả nhà? Ví dụ tôi cần này. Vậy thì để
phân tích đối thủ trong ngành Fnb
[âm nhạc]
thì bây giờ mình copy đúng cái câu của
một bạn là
bóc khối lượng dựa trên bản vẽ. Có một
bạn nữa là bốc khối lượng tại nó hơi
chung chung. Đúng bạn phải hiểu sâu về
AutoCAD. [âm nhạc]
Rồi vậy thì bây giờ đó
cái này mình chỉ đang nói và hỏi mọi
người thử một số thông tin thôi nha. Còn
lại trong này nó vẫn là mang tính chất
chung chung. Còn ở đây nếu như mà anh
chị muốn đi chuyên sâu là mình [âm nhạc]
sẽ khai báo ra cái nội dung à chi tiết
hơn. Đó. Vậy thì lúc này để coi
[âm nhạc]
còn một cái nữa sắp xếp kế hoạch sản
xuất.
Rồi tạm thời nhé, [âm nhạc] tạm thời
Minh sẽ lấy luôn cái câu phần này. Nó
chưa mặc dù nó chưa đủ chi tiết do cái
mẫu của mình nhưng mình sẽ lấy như
[âm nhạc] cái này để coi nó hoạt động
như thế nào.
Rồi ok. [âm nhạc]
Tôi confirm thì mình có thể chi tiết
được nó là tôi confirm ha. Ok.
Thì mọi người yên tâm ở trong cái phần
này nó sẽ tự động nó đi ra nó hỏi mình
nè,
nó hỏi thêm nhé.
Ha.
Rồi
thì với cái câu from lúc nãy mình đưa
ban đầu là câu Megaf gốc đó mọi người
đưa vào thì nội dung là mọi người trả
hình dung [âm nhạc] rồi. Bây giờ mình
chỉ lấy đúng đến một cái câu của một bạn
thôi à đưa vào trong này để cho ai nó
thực thi. Ví dụ bóc khối lượng vừa trên
bảng vẽ xây [âm nhạc] dựng thì nó sẽ ra
như thế nào? phân loại nhiệm vụ kỹ thuật
nè cộng phân tích bốc tách khối lượng
quantity
tch cur [âm nhạc] bản vẽ xây dựng để lập
bản khối lượng phục vụ cho dự toán và
thi công giả định do chưa có thêm thông
tin mọi người thấy không ạ tự ai nó sẽ
phân tích ra là do mình chưa có thêm
thông tin chưa rõ [âm nhạc] ràng á nếu
thực tế khác với giả định hãy báo lại để
tôi điều chỉnh yếu tố loại [âm nhạc]
công trình giả định dân dụng nè loại bản
vẽ kiến trúc kết cấu upload [âm nhạc]
hình ảnh PDF. Mục đích là cái gì ạ? Khi
mình cung cấp những cái đầu vào này, bổ
sung thêm cho nó thì nó [âm nhạc] sẽ cho
mình cái mẫu from được không ạ? From nó
sẽ cụ thể hơn, [âm nhạc] rõ ràng hơn chứ
nó không chung chung. Kiểu kiểu như vậy.
Và cái đầu ra mình mong muốn là cái gì?
[âm nhạc] Bản khối lượng phân loại mình
mong muốn là cái gì? Người dùng from là
ai? Kỹ sư dự toán hay là nhà thầu? Chủ
đầu tư? Tiêu chuẩn định mức xây dựng
[âm nhạc] Việt Nam? Thì mọi người thấy
như ban nãy là do mình thiết kế cái mẫu
[âm nhạc] này nó sẽ cho ra ba phiên bản
được không cả nhà? Thì những yếu tố này
hiện tại là mình chưa cung cấp đầy đủ do
mình chỉ nói là bóp khối [âm nhạc] lượng
dựa trên bản vẻ nó vẫn khá chung chung
cho nên nó sẽ gì ạ? Giả định [âm nhạc]
có nghĩa là nó sẽ cung cấp một loại dữ
liệu giả định vào để cho nó làm đủ cái
nội dung và nó đưa ra mẫu form output.
[âm nhạc]
Đây phiên bản một dùng khi cần kết quả
nhanh. Bản vẽ đơn bản vẽ đơn giản phiên
bản hai là dùng cho này.
Phiên bản hai dùng cho hầu hết trường
hợp [âm nhạc] thực tế bạn là kỹ sư dự
toán 10 năm. Đó. Rồi phiên bản mẫu form
chuyên sâu dùng do công trình phức tạp,
hồ sơ đấu thầu cần độ chính [âm nhạc]
xác cao. Vai trò bạn là kỹ sư dự toán
xây dựng chuyên nghiệp 15 năm. Làm việc
gì đấy, đọc bản vẽ kiến trúc vân vân. À
ngữ [âm nhạc] cảnh tôi sẽ cung cấp bản
vẽ xây dựng nhiệm vụ là
bạn lập bản khối lượng hoàn chỉnh
[âm nhạc] chính xác đủ điều kiện làm cơ
sở. Quy trình thực hiện bước một kiểm
tra đầu vào. Bước hai đọc. Bước ba, phụ
phân cấp vân vân. Thì lúc này mình sẽ
bắt đầu nha mọi người. Mình sẽ bắt đầu
đi cho nó thực thi cái cái [âm nhạc] mẫu
form này luôn rồi mọi người sẽ hình dung
nó rõ hơn. Vậy thì lúc này nó cuối cùng
nó tóm tắt là gì ạ? Cách dùng là copy
from [âm nhạc] đưa vào chat GPT hay là
Germini blog rồi sau đó là cái gì ạ?
Enter chạy [âm nhạc] rồi up log cái hình
ảnh bản dự toán đó mọi người. Bản vẽ nè
để [âm nhạc] chi? Để nó tính toán ra
được cái số lượng cái khối lượng bóc cái
khối lượng đó ra. Vậy mình sẽ copy nè.
Được không cả [âm nhạc] nhà? Ngay đây
mình đứng đây mình copy. Mình tạo một
cái new conversation
luồng chat mới mình [âm nhạc] nó qua.
Rồi vậy thì đến cái đoạn này mọi người
thấy là đây nó gần gần giống với cái
việc là chúng ta đã từng làm với những
[âm nhạc] cái lùng chat mà trước đây
chat GPT giao vai trò hay là Zemini.
Chúng ta hay giao [âm nhạc] vai trò và
ờ các đầu một công việc mà giao cho
[âm nhạc] ai sẽ làm được không cả nhà?
Thì Minh cũng đang làm tương tự giống
mọi người.
Tới đoạn này cũng làm tương tự giống mọi
người. Đây mình enter
đấy.
Rồi mọi người nhìn chỗ này nhé. Nếu như
chúng ta có một cái bản vẽ kiến
[âm nhạc] trúc, bản vẽ kết cấu, bản vẽ
mép gì đó mình không rành về cái điện
nước này ha. thuyết minh kỹ thuật
[âm nhạc] thì mình sẽ cung cấp dữ liệu
vào cho nó bắt đầu nó sẽ tiến hành.
Nhưng cái máu chốt ở đây là cái gì ạ? À
máu chốt ở đây mình không có ừ mình chưa
đề cập đến cái việc là
là là cung cấp bản vẽ như thế [âm nhạc]
nào. Nhưng mình đang muốn nói là cái để
từ cái nội dung này, [âm nhạc] từ cái
con chatbot này mình sẽ vận dụng vào cái
gì ạ? mình sẽ biến nó thành một cái
chatbot trên cái nền tảng này. Và chỉ
cần không lần sau khi gặp lại trường hợp
này á, lần sau khi gặp lại trường hợp
này chúng ta sẽ là sao ạ? Chúng ta sẽ
đưa nó thành một cái chest boss và gọi
tên nó. Ê bản vẽ của tao nè, thực thi
đi. Ê đây là cái bảng m này hay là đây
là bản thuyết mình kỹ thuật ta. phân
tích đi. Mình không [âm nhạc] cần gọi
đến cái câu này nữa, không cần nhúng cái
câu này luôn. [âm nhạc] Được không cả
nhà? Thay vì bây giờ là mình đang để như
thế này là chờ đầu vào đúng không? Thì
lần sau mình đưa [âm nhạc] luôn cái lùng
chat mới và chỉ cần đưa file đính kèm
lên copy đường dẫn của cái file
bản vẽ gì đấy vân vân. Rồi chỉ cần gọi
cái tên đó thôi. Vậy thì cách làm ở trên
này tạm thời với anh chị là người mới
cũng xin nhắc lại lần nữa. Tạm [âm nhạc]
thời chúng ta là người mới chỉ cần hình
dung là cái con AI này nó có thể làm
được những gì. Còn về các bước để làm á
thì mọi người bắt đầu có thể bắt đầu lên
mạng có thể tìm tài liệu, bắt đầu có thể
xem tiếp ha. Rồi mình tạm thời để vẫn
cái lùng chá nằm đây nó không bị mất nha
mọi người. Đây nó vẫn đang nằm đây thôi.
Nó chờ mình đây.
Rồi nhưng ở trong này mình sẽ mở ra.
À hãy
tạo trước nãy đóng gói luôn đi.
Đóng
rồi
tôi nói
skill.
[hắng giọng]
thì
việc gọi [âm nhạc] tên
là dùng hay
rồi. Ờ mình chỉ đánh đúng một cái câu
này thôi nha. Mọi người hãy đóng gói lại
hãy đóng gói giúp [âm nhạc] tôi nội dung
sau thành skill. Và cái chữ này tạm thời
ở đây mọi người là người mới cũng chưa
hình dung. Chúng ta sẽ
cũng chỉ để cái câu này [âm nhạc] qua
một bên rồi cái chữ này qua một bên và
khi cần mọi người có thể hỏi à ai skill
ở trong cái bối cảnh này mà chỗ anh Minh
chia sẻ tại sao lại dùng cái từ skill
[âm nhạc] thì lúc này ai sẽ diễn tả cho
mọi người. À nó không phải là từ tiếng
Anh dịch sang tiếng Việt là AI có nghĩa
là skill lúc này nó là kỹ năng nha. Mà
skill lúc này nó như là một cái danh từ
riêng. AI lúc này nó sẽ hiểu cần phải
làm cái gì khi mình nói đóng gói thành
skill. [âm nhạc] Rồi để mình thử cho cả
nhà.
Thì khi mà mình yêu cầu nó đóng gói
thành skill [âm nhạc] lúc này như ban
đầu mình có nói là cái gì ạ? Mục đích
của mình là biến Megafm thành trợ lý
được không cả nhà? Biến Megafm thành trợ
lý. Khi mà đã có trợ lý rồi thì sao ạ?
Lúc này mình chỉ việc bạn Lan ơi, bạn gì
Minh ơi, bạn A, bạn B, bạn C ơi, tôi có
cái công việc này thi giúp tôi đi làm
đi. Đây nè. hồ sơ của tôi nè và báo cáo
cho tôi mỗi ngày vào lúc 8:00 sáng được
không cả nhà? Đó là một trong những cái
yếu tố mà mình đang muốn nói. 2:00 chiều
[âm nhạc] 7:00 tối với nhân viên bình
thường chúng ta có thể là 5:00 chiều là
chúng ta đã hết ca. Ví dụ vậy là hết giờ
đi về. Nhưng với Ai này chúng ta có
[âm nhạc] thể yêu cầu là 3:00 4 gi 5:00
miễn sao là để đó và yêu cầu nó lên lịch
nó thực thi được không cả nhà?
Rồi ờ nó sẽ tự động nó chạy và nó nó nó
làm cho việc cho mình. Miễn sao mình có
cung cấp dữ liệu cho nó. Đây là hồ sơ nè
của [âm nhạc] tôi nè. Bạn làm đi. Đối
với những cái trường hợp nhất là những
cái trợ lý mà hay làm việc online á. Hồi
nãy có một bạn nói về trường hợp
nghiên cứu dữ liệu, phân tích dữ liệu
hay là làm về thủ tập thông tin trên web
nó là một dạng đó.
Rồi.
Ok. Thì mọi người bắt đầu đến đoạn này
[âm nhạc] mọi người đọc sơ lược thôi
nhé. À bây giờ đây khi nó đóng gói xong
skill đã được đóng gói và kích hoạt
thành công.
skill mới có tên là construction
BQ [âm nhạc] engineer. Vị trí là như thế
này. Cách gọi chỉ cần nhắc đến bất kỳ từ
[âm nhạc] nào trong danh sách trigger là
AN sẽ tự kích hoạt bốc khối lượng lập BQ
lập tiên lượng dự toán xây dựng tính
khối lượng ô sơ [âm nhạc] thầu được
không ạ? Vậy thì lúc này nó tính là
skill bao gồm những cái gì trong đây nó
[âm nhạc] là
dự toán 15 năm kỹ sư dự toán 15 năm
thành thạo cái gì đây? Rồi năm bước
output là bốn bảng tổng hợp năm lỗi
thường gặp ừ gì đó. Từ conversation
[âm nhạc] tiếp theo bạn chỉ cần gửi bản
vẽ và nói bóc khối lượng là A sẽ tự nhận
ra vai trò kỹ [âm nhạc] sư dự toán và
chạy đúng quy trình. Nếu như ở đây có
bạn nào có cái cái cái bản vẽ thì cho
mình [âm nhạc] một cái bản vẽ hoặc là
cái gì đó để mình làm thử ha. Còn bây
giờ tạm thời mình sẽ yêu cầu nó cho một
cái giả định nhé. Được không ạ? Tại
[âm nhạc] vì lúc này mình chưa có để cho
mọi người hình dung thôi thì cách nó gọi
như thế nào. À đây nó nói nè. Từ
conversation tiếp theo bạn chỉ cần gửi
bản vẽ cộng với bóc khối lượng. Thì ở
đây Minh cũng giống như mọi người
[âm nhạc] giả định nhá. Nói đúng cái câu
này luôn.
Đi qua một cái luồng mới tiếp. Và
[âm nhạc] lúc này nó không giống như ở
bên nền tảng
Germin
hay là bên chat GBT mình phải dùng
[âm nhạc] tới cái chatbot mình yêu cầu
là đúng cái con chatbot đó rồi đánh vào
nội dung [âm nhạc] rồi đưa nội dung lên
tập tin lên rồi mình mới làm việc với nó
không cần với trường hợp này ở bên này
chúng ta có các cách làm việc như là nãy
trường hợp với bóc khối lượng thì chúng
ta chỉ cần gọi là gì vậy bốc khối lượng
[âm nhạc] đúng không? Bóng khối lượng là
gọi tên thẳng nó ra. Còn không thì mình
đánh dấu chéo này.
Bóc khối lượng a hồi nãy là contraction.
Contraction
à
mình nhớ hồi nãy cái tên đó phải ta.
Rồi không sao để construction thì bây
[âm nhạc] giờ mình nói giả định đi.
Mình quay lại cái này tí xíu nhé. À
[âm nhạc] giả định
tôi chưa bỏ
bạn vẻ
bạn [âm nhạc] niệm
thì
à bạn
cho số
của
dạ
cộng
rồi [âm nhạc] thì do mình chưa có một
cái bản vẽ à những cái thông tin thông
số đó vân vân thì mình yêu cầu nó thực
thi cho một cái giả định đây skill đã l
bắt đầu thực thi nhà ở dung dụng hai
tầng máy bằng
được không Cả nhà thì đây là một cái
luồng [âm nhạc] chá đúng không cả nhà?
Mình tạm thời mình vẫn để cho nó thực
thi nha. Mình đi qua một cái luồng mới.
Mọi người nhìn vào cái bánh xe này nha.
Nó vẫn đang quay. [âm nhạc] Mình sẽ đi
qua một cái luồng khác được không cả
nhà? Và mình gọi tên
>> [âm nhạc]
>> Viral.
Đây
đây là một cái skill khác. Đây là một
cái [âm nhạc] skill còn gọi là skill là
cái từ nào á thì mọi người bắt đầu đi
resarch thêm. Còn ở trên này có thể hình
dung nó một dạng trợ lý thôi. Minh quen
miệng gọi cho này nó skill. Thì lúc này
Minh sẽ có đóng gói lại rồi và trend
viral Fer giống như nãy có một bạn hỏi
mình á là làm một cái chatbot mà đi
research nghiên cứu thông tin trên web.
Đây nó là một dạng này. Khi user yêu cầu
tìm trend research xu hướng hoặc nhắc
đến tìm trend. Đây mọi người thấy không?
Một cách gọi của mình á là [âm nhạc]
trend viral file fer. Cái này là do mình
đặt tên từ trước còn không á là mình chỉ
cần bấm là tìm trend giúp tôi hôm nay có
gì được. Đó là một cách khác. Vậy thì
bây giờ mình thử với con jackpot này nó
sẽ chạy [âm nhạc] như thế nào
đó. Mình chưa hề nói thêm một cái gì nha
mọi người. [âm nhạc] Mình chưa nói là
tìm trend gì nha. Nếu cụ thể mình có thể
nói tìm trend về
ừ nó bắt đầu nó hỏi mình là muốn tìm
trend về cái gì luôn nè. Được không mọi
người? Lúc nãy là mình chưa hề đề cập
đến nội dung gì. Bây giờ mình muốn tìm
về vấn đề gì đó nó sẽ liệt kê một số
hoặc là mình muốn tìm nội dung liên quan
đến gì à giải trí đi. Tại vì trong này
nó bắt đầu nó quen một số cái ứng dụng
ngày của mình. Ví dụ như solo [âm nhạc]
Google Coding
thông tin giải trí
rồi sắp tới Google Cup rồi [âm nhạc] thể
thao luôn
rồi thể thao thì nó gợi ý nó hỏi lại
tiếp mình BB hay là thể thao gì à phong
trào Việt Nam
từ nào rõ ràng hơn đó mọi người.
Rồi [âm nhạc] thì lúc này bắt đầu nó sẽ
tự động đi research nha. Tự động đi
resarch thể thao gì đó vân vân. Rồi
trong cái quá trình nó thực thi nha bắt
đầu nó tự động n để coi coi nó đi ra nó
tìm nè mọi người.
Mình có thể mình click vào đây [âm nhạc]
ha. Mình xem.
Rồi, ở đây mình sẽ đi qua lại coi bên
này nó đang đi tới đâu rồi.
Đây.
Rồi. Ok. Bước một thông số bản vẽ
[âm nhạc] giả định. Đây là một cái công
trình nhà ở dong dụng hai tầng máy bằng.
Rồi check list đầu vào tất cả vì đây là
bản vẽ giả định đã được định [âm nhạc]
nghĩa đầy đủ. Không biết là có bạn hồi
nãy có cho mình được một cái bản vẽ là
bạn nào có liên quan đến cái công việc
này cho mình cái thông tin á để mình có
thể làm luôn. Thì ở đây nó sẽ ra bước
hai [âm nhạc] là hệ thống hóa bản vẽ nè.
Đó mặt bằng như thế nào nè. Bước ba nè.
Nó chỉ không chỉ dừng lại cung cấp cái
số liệu này nha mọi người. Nó có thể
xuất thành một cái file PDF, xuất thành
một file [âm nhạc] HTML, xuất thành một
file Word, xuất thành một file Excel.
Tùy theo cái mong muốn của mình. À tùy
theo [âm nhạc] cái mong muốn của mình
nhá. Đây
thì nó cho ra đến cái nhóm F luôn là hệ
thống kỹ thuật. Và bước B là tổng hợp
theo nhóm.
kiểm [âm nhạc] định chéo vân vân. Bước
năm là cảnh báo và lưu ý checklist.
[âm nhạc] Tiếp theo là à cung cấp bản v
thực tế. Tôi sẽ cho thấy số liệu. Ok. À
thì cơ bản đây là một vài cái thông tin
giả định thì mọi người thấy nó đã ra như
thế này. Và nếu như mình yêu cầu nó ờ
output ra
một dạng file gì đấy thì mình sẽ nói ha.
Thì nó sẽ làm ra cho mình. Rồi thì trong
cái quá trình mình đợi có một bạn nói là
sẽ gửi bản vẽ AutoCAD đến thời điểm hiện
tại [âm nhạc] chính bản thân mình cũng
chưa thử AutoCAD cái file AutoCAD ở trên
này nha mọi người. Để tí nữa AI thử coi
như thế nào. Rồi bình thường mình chỉ
đọc những cái file PDF filew [âm nhạc]
file Excel PowerPoint
hình ảnh.
Ồ quá nhiều thông tin ở đây nó vẫn chưa
resarch [âm nhạc] xong.
bắt đầu có thông tin sẽ đóng gói lại và
nó đưa vào trong cái content nè mọi
người
để coi coi còn những cái thông tin nào
nó đang đi kiếm.
Và như vậy á thì mọi người trong cái quá
trình đợi để cho [âm nhạc] bạn một bạn
nữa gửi thì mình sẽ quay lại cái chatbot
này. Thì tạm thời mình chưa có số liệu
và chưa có [âm nhạc] file thực tế thì
mình sẽ đi làm một cái chatbot khác được
không cả nhà? Hồi nãy là lúc này là mình
đang là nhập from mình vẫn đang đi vào
cái luồng chat [âm nhạc] cũ rồi nha mọi
người. Tôi cần firm bóc tch. Rồi vậy thì
hồi nãy có một bạn cũng có nói với mình
là để coi coi sắp [âm nhạc] xếp kế hoạch
sản xuất. Ok thử một cái chatbot khác.
Cái buổi hôm nay chủ yếu là để cho mọi
người hình dung được nhé là cách vận
hành của chatbot trên antiravity như thế
nào và sau đó mình sẽ yêu cầu nó lập
lịch lập thời gian nó tự đi vận hành như
thế nào. Tôi confirm sắp xếp kế hoạch
sản xuất. [âm nhạc] Rồi mình copy câu
này nên tạm thời nó sai lỗ chính tả mình
để luôn cho nó tự nó chạy coi nó hiểu
như thế nào ha.
Rồi
chiến lược cộng tự động hóa quy trình
lập kế hoạch thì nó trong đây nó phân
loại là kế hoạch sản xuất cho cái gì nữa
nè
loại ngành sản xuất là gì thực phẩm mai
mặt cơ khí vân vân và mình chưa cung cấp
đầy đủ nó sẽ yêu cầu mình cung cấp những
cái yếu tố như là để nó chưa đầy đủ thì
cái con mình nó cũng không có gọi là
mình tạo ra trợ lý thì Và trợ lý này nó
chưa gọi là hoàn hảo đó mọi người.
Đây nè. Do chưa có thêm thông tin vì
mình chiến lược sản xuất mà sản xuất cho
ngành gì ở đây nó có đó nè. Loại sản
xuất là thực phẩm may mặt cơ khí điện tử
quy mô sản [âm nhạc] xuất đầu vào là gì
số ba đầu vào là gì bốn đầu ra mong muốn
có ràng buộc gì hay không vân vân thì
lúc này chckbot của mình trợ lý của mình
nó [âm nhạc] sẽ tối ưu hơn rất là nhiều
khi mình chỉ cung cấp chung chung được
không cả nhà. Nhưng về yếu tố giả định
là nó sẽ như thế này. [âm nhạc] Báo lại
nếu thực tế khác tôi sẽ điều chỉnh ngay.
Đối với ngành gì ạ? Ngành sản [âm nhạc]
xuất hàng hóa có thể tùy chỉnh đầu vào
đó là danh sách đơn hàng, thông tin công
suất, nhân lực à lịch sản xuất theo ngày
theo tuần. Người dùng đó là ai ạ? Người
dùng sẽ là quản lý sản xuất, kế hoạch
viên hay là chữ [âm nhạc] ca.
Vừa rồi nó sẽ cho ba mẫu form như thế
này. [âm nhạc] Một là dùng ngắn gọn
cho trường hợp dữ liệu đơn hàng cần lên
lịch nhanh. Rồi trường hợp hai dùng cho
hầu [âm nhạc] hết cái trường hợp thực tế
thì cái mẫu nó như thế này và mình luôn
luôn thích nhất là cái mẫu front thứ ba
nó sẽ đi sâu hơn. Dùng cho nhà máy có
nhiều dây chuyền, nhiều sản phẩm yêu cầu
tối ưu cao. [âm nhạc] Bạn là một chuyên
gia hoạch định sản xuất cấp cao am hiểu
hệ thống [âm nhạc] EP, lý thuyết tốc và
tối ưu lịch sản xuất đa dây chuyền. Bạn
tư duy như một là Operation Manager cân
bằng giữa on time, delivery, hiệu suất
máy, tồn khoử cảnh như thế nào đây? Rồi
bản vẽ
ờ mình cung cấp ra bản là bản vẽ mình
xin lỗi bản một là [âm nhạc] đơn hàng
bản hai là như thế nào
rồi bắt đầu nó đến đoạn này là quy trình
sáu bước phân tích đầu vào kiểm tra các
thứ thì cái from này nó sẽ đi ra mọi
người thấy không bắt đầu nó sẽ đi ra
từng bước như thế này rồi nó sẽ
[âm nhạc] nói gì lưu ý nếu bạn cho tôi
biết thêm ngành sản xuất cụ thể là gì
thực phẩm may mặt ok cụ thể
là may mặt
đấy.
Như vậy thì mọi người bắt đầu hình dung
được không ạ? bắt đầu mơ hồ hình dung
được cái giữa chatbot ở trên Germin hay
là chatbot ở trên chat GPT bắt đầu nó có
cái sự gì mà sai sai ở đây so với cái
chỗ chatbot này [âm nhạc] không ạ?
Nghĩa là ngay tại cái trợ lý [âm nhạc]
hay mình nói đơn giản là chatbot ở trên
cái nền tảng mà Aen có nghĩa là những
cái công cụ mọi người nghe đến gần đây
đó là A plot nè anti gravity nè đó hay
gọi chung là [âm nhạc] Aiz đó đại khái
là nó cho mình được quyền trong
[âm nhạc] can thiệp vào trợ lý ngay lập
tức thay vì chúng ta phải đi vào bên
trong setting rồi cập nhật vào [âm nhạc]
construction rồi hướng dẫn vân vân với
với cái công cụ AI mới bây giờ khi chúng
ta làm việc và chúng ta cảm thấy là cái
gì ạ? Cái phần này cái chatbot này là
vẫn còn thiếu những yếu tố A, yếu tố B,
yếu tố C chưa đầy đủ, [âm nhạc] chúng ta
có thể can thiệp vào đứng ngay tại cái
luồng chat đó mà chỉ yêu cầu thôi mọi
người yêu cầu. [âm nhạc] Ờ đây là cái
phần kiến thức mẫu nè. Kiến thức này là
mới nè. Hôm nay nó phát sinh vấn đề nè.
Mình sẽ yêu cầu nó là hãy cập nhật vào.
Hãy cập nhật vào. Mình chỉ cần nói vậy
thôi. Hãy bổ sung vào
được không ạ? Như vậy thì lúc này AI
mà gọi là skill á nó sẽ học được thêm
cái dữ liệu. Tại sao mà người ta gọi là
skill? Skill chính là kỹ năng của mọi
người á. Thay vì ở ng bên ngoài từ tiếng
Anh có nghĩa là mình dùng từ kỹ năng.
Nhưng ở đây chính là cái gì ạ?
>> [âm nhạc]
>> Mình đang nói về cái chuyên môn nghiệp
vụ thì không nói rồi nhưng mà nó làm
việc lâu ngày với những bạn mà làm việc
lâu năm mình chúng ta sẽ có những cái bộ
kỹ [âm nhạc] năng riêng đúng không ạ? Và
những bộ kỹ năng này chúng ta có thể đưa
lên đóng gói lại thành một cái sản phẩm
cố [âm nhạc] định gọi là tài sản số đó
mọi người. Và tích lũy theo thời gian.
Hôm nay chúng ta làm cái này, mai chúng
ta làm cái kia [âm nhạc] và chúng ta
thấy cái này còn thiếu cái bộ kỹ năng
này, skill này còn thiếu, chúng ta sẽ
bắt đầu tích lũy vào thêm. Chỉ cần nói
là hãy cập nhật vào skill này, hãy cập
nhật vào cái công cụ à giống như hồi nãy
mình có đang làm về cái cái
bảng bóp tách khối lượng đó đúng không
ạ? Thì lúc này mình chỉ cần nói là đây
là cái bản mẫu nè, bản vẽ nè,
[hắng giọng] đây là số liệu nè, hãy cập
nhật [âm nhạc] vào đi và đem coi như cái
này là số liệu mẫu sau này dựa trên cái
này bạn có thể phân tích mà không cần
phải mất thời gian vân vân. Thì cứ như
vậy mỗi ngày chúng ta sẽ đưa lên update
dần update dần. Nó khác [âm nhạc] hoàn
toàn với chat GBT là chatbot chúng ta
phải tạo ra hướng dẫn rồi bổ sung thêm
rồi add file vân vân với công cụ Ei dần
bây giờ là không cần nữa, chỉ nói và nói
thôi. Như vậy nó sẽ rất là nhanh ha.
Kiểu như nhân viên bình thường là việc
lâu ngày mà tích lũy [âm nhạc] kiến thức
vậy thôi. Được không cả nhà? Như vậy thì
đến cái đoạn này mình đã làm ra một cái
đoạn from về may mặt.
Dùng cho nhà [âm nhạc] máy nhiều truyền,
nhiều khách hàng cần phân tích botnet và
KBI à chuẩn cho xuất khẩu. Thì lúc nãy
có một bạn có nói về cái làm kế hoạch
sản xuất nhưng mà chưa biết là kế hoạch
sản xuất cụ [âm nhạc] thể của bạn là
đang mong muốn là gì.
À em nạp vào dữ liệu bằng tiếng Trung ai
có thể đọc được không ạ?
À đúng rồi Phúc à đúng rồi Phú trả lời
đúng rồi đó. Ở đây là không có rào cản
ngôn ngữ đâu. Hiện nay [âm nhạc]
hoàn toàn mọi thứ nó được tự động hóa ai
nó đọc được rất là nhiều cái ngôn ngữ
khác nhau rồi. Rồi vậy thì mình lại mang
cái câu này [âm nhạc] sang cái lược
chest mới mình lại tạo ra skill và lần
sau mình chỉ cần làm cái gì ạ? Mình chỉ
cung cấp cho nó cái dữ liệu là mình mong
[âm nhạc] muốn làm cái gì ạ. Ví dụ như
là bổ sung cho tôi tăng ca nè. xử lý đơn
rust hoặc tích hợp thống kê gì đấy vân
vân thì lúc này [âm nhạc] nó sẽ tậc thi
đúng không ạ? À Minh sẽ làm thử tại vì
có một bạn đang hỏi về tiếng Trung Minh
sẽ làm thử một cái cây study về tiếng
Trung luôn nhé cho bạn thấy về cái
trường hợp tiếng Trung. Rồi như vậy thì
lúc này mình sẽ đưa qua bên này hãy đóng
gối
thằng skill
cho nội dung s
lúc này mình sẽ nói đơn giản hơn ha mình
không đi phức tạp nữa hồi nãy lúc mình
cố gắng giải thích cho mọi người là ở
luồng chat mới tái sử dụng vân vân gì
đấy là để cho mọi người hình dung còn
trường hợp Đây
mình sẽ nói ngắn gọn hơn. Rồi trong cái
quá trình mà nó đang đóng gói nè mọi
người. Tôi đã xem một map chuẩn. Giờ tôi
sẽ đóng gói from thành skill chính thức.
Như vậy [âm nhạc] thì lúc này mình sẽ có
một trợ lý riêng và nằm trong bộ nhớ
trên máy tính của mình. Lần sau chỉ việc
gọi tên thôi là kế hoạch sản xuất cho
ngành may mặt. Lúc sắp tới nó sẽ đặt ra
một cái tên của mình. Mình thích cái tên
đó hay không mình có thể hình dung mình
chỉnh sửa ha. Thì có một bạn đang đề cập
đến cái dữ liệu tiếng Trung thì sẵn đây
mình [âm nhạc] sẽ thị phạm luôn cái phần
trợ lý tạo dịch thuật. Trợ lý dịch thuật
chuyên làm về cái việc là ngôn ngữ tài
liệu tiếng Trung
hoặc là những cái ngôn ngữ tiếng Anh,
tiếng vân vân sang cái tiếng Việt và
trình bày ở dưới dạng nội dung ờ như thế
nào. Trình bày ở dưới dạng nội dung
[âm nhạc] mà mọi người
đây
Minh sẽ làm lại nha. Đầu tiên là Minh sẽ
để cho mọi người những anh chị [âm nhạc]
chưa thấy hoặc chưa xem cái dữ liệu hôm
trước mình đã làm. Đây là một dạng nội
dung.
Mọi người thấy không? À có ai không nhìn
thấy không ta?
Mình sẽ mở một cái file góc.
Rồi [âm nhạc] như vậy thì mọi người bắt
đầu nhìn thấy nha. Cái đây là nội dung
từ cái tài liệu góc là tiếng Hoa.
Mình sẽ
mở [âm nhạc] lại cái đây.
Mọi người vẫn nhìn thấy được cái file
này của mình đúng không ạ? Nội dung mà
mình đang mở đúng không ạ?
Đó.
Cẩm nang minh họa chẩn [âm nhạc] đoán
bằng lưỡi thè lưỡi ra và chữa. Đó đây là
cái tài liệu của một bạn đang học về
ngành
gọi là giống như là bên sức khỏe đó mọi
người. Hoàn toàn nha [âm nhạc] hoàn toàn
tất cả
là đều tiến hoa hết 205 trang.
Rồi như vậy thì lúc này chatbot mình nó
sẽ như thế nào ạ? Trong cái quá trình
mình chỉ yêu cầu nó đúng có một cái
gọi là cái gì ạ? Đúng một câu thôi mọi
người.
Một câu thôi [âm nhạc] là nó sẽ dịch ra
ngay. Và các bước còn lại là mình chỉnh
sửa lại cho nó đẹp thôi.
Đâu rồi để mình đưa lên trên cùng.
Đây
đây nè mọi người. Kéo hết rồi đó. Rồi
mọi người nhớ mình sẽ đưa cái đường link
cái đường dẫn của cái file [âm nhạc] đó
vào đúng mới nằm ở phía sau. Có nghĩa là
mình có cái file này được cả nha. Đây
cảm nang minh họa nè mình để ở phía sau
này và mình không nói thêm một câu nào
khác. Mình không hề có hướng dẫn mình
cũng chẳng có yêu cầu nó làm là bạn phải
a phải b không cần. Và nó tự động nó đi
lập kế hoạch được không cả nhà?
Implement Lập [âm nhạc] kế hoạch nhé. Là
trợ lý này của mình đã được làm từ
trước. Nó sẽ thực thi như thế nào ạ? Đầu
tiên là nó phải đi OCR. OCR là scan dữ
[âm nhạc] liệu thì hình dung như vậy
thôi. Nó đọc cái file này thôi.
Về chi tiết thì mai mốt anh chị có thời
gian có thể tìm hiểu thêm những cái này
nó rất là hay trên AI nhé. Từ OCR AI nó
[âm nhạc] có thể làm được những gì rồi
dịch thuật nè, đóng gói cẩm ngang nè,
bằng lưỡi vân vân thì lúc này nó sẽ lập
cho mình một cái plan rất là chi tiết
các bước nó làm. Mọi người có thời
[âm nhạc] gian thì làm việc với AI AN
mọi người sẽ đọc những cái bảng mà
implement land này mọi người sẽ
[âm nhạc] hình dung ra được các bước AI
nó làm việc như thế nào. Từ đó mình cũng
học được thêm rất là nhiều ha. Rồi vậy
thì quay lại cái chỗ đoạn này.
[khịt mũi]
Với trường hợp này á nó sẽ tự động nó
làm ra đến cái đoạn này và nó tôi sẽ bắt
đầu thực thi ngay sau khi được sự đồng ý
và lựa chọn phương [âm nhạc] án từ bạn.
Rồi nó hỏi mình nè. Một là phương án,
thứ hai là dịch toàn văn 100%. Hai là
dịch chèn liên kết ở đây thôi. Có nghĩa
là nó chỉ tóm đưa cái phần nào đây. Thì
mình yêu cầu là chọn phương án gì rồi
bắt đầu mình yêu [âm nhạc] cầu chọn
thôi. Rồi bắt đầu các bước còn lại là nó
sẽ làm ha. Nó tự động nó đi thực thi
[âm nhạc] nó làm gì đó mình không có rõ
là nó tự động nó build thêm cái A, cái
B, cái C gì đấy được không cả [âm nhạc]
nhà? Đó, trong đây là các bước mà lúc
trước nó tự nó làm nè. Nó sẽ chia ra
nhé. Và sẵn tiện đây thì Minh cũng nói
thêm. Mọi người nhìn nè,
trong này nó sẽ có nhiều chương đúng
không mọi người? Nó sẽ có nhiều
[âm nhạc] chương. Đây là mục nè.
Đại khái như vậy ha. Có nhiều chương.
Thì lúc này [âm nhạc] với AI
gravity này tại một thời điểm tại một
thời điểm mình nhấn mạnh luôn tại một
thời điểm [âm nhạc] thay vì lúc trước
chúng ta dùng những cái loại AI kia
những cái loại AI truyền thống á Germini
Chat GPT nó sẽ [âm nhạc] chạy từng đầu
Việt một. Có nghĩa là chạy xong bước thứ
nhất, chạy xong cái chương thứ nhất thì
nó mới đến chương thứ hai được không cả
nhà? [âm nhạc] Rồi đến 3 đến 4 đến 5 cứ
như vậy lần lượt lần lượt cho đến khi
hết. Còn với AI này nó sẽ thực thi như
thế nào ạ? Ở trong đây có tổng cộng là 9
chương, 10 chương gì đấy. Nó sẽ thực thi
bằng cách là nó bổ nhỏ cái dữ liệu này
ra. Bổ nhỏ cái dữ liệu trong cái file
này ra và sau đó [âm nhạc] nó chạy cùng
một lúc 10 cái chương này được không cả
nhà?
bổ nhỏ ra chạy cùng một lúc chứ không
cần đi đợi là ông A làm xong rồi tôi mới
làm tiếp tới cái bước [âm nhạc] B đ làm
tiếp bước kế không cần vì mọi người hình
dung nhé rõ ràng tại vì cái dữ liệu
trong này á [âm nhạc] không hề liên quan
đến nhau theo kiểu gọi là max xích tôi
thiếu cái kia thì tôi làm không được cái
này tôi thiếu cái phần này thì tôi không
làm được bước kế tiếp không dữ liệu cái
file này mỗi [âm nhạc] file là một hình
ảnh này nè mọi người hình dung n cái
hình này nè mỗi một phần này là một phần
độc lập Thì lúc này ấy ai nó sẽ tự động
nó hình dung ra được à tại sao tao không
chia ra bổ nhỏ ra để ta làm nhanh hơn
được không cả nhà? Giống như mình giao
việc cho trợ lý thôi. Trợ lý bây giờ là
trợ lý rồi nó thông minh hoặc là nó có
biết cách nó có những cái tip nó có
những cái thủ thuật đúng không cả nhà?
giống như mình vậy thôi. Và cách nào để
làm tối ưu nhất giống như chúng ta đi
làm vậy thôi. Có thể là mọi người sẽ
dùng germin, có thể là dùng [âm nhạc]
ứng dụng giống như cái buổi hôm trước Võ
Hàng có chia sẻ với mọi người cách dùng
trợ lý gọi là as Germini ở trên cái
trình duyệt [âm nhạc] Google Trom hay là
mình sử dụng là trực tiếp AI phân tích
dữ liệu ở trong Google Se. Đó là một
phần những cái tip mà mình để cho tối ưu
hóa công việc của [âm nhạc] mình lên
đúng không ạ? Cải tiền năng suất. Thì
với trường hợp AI mới bây giờ cũng vậy.
Khi mình đưa cái dữ liệu vào và nó hình
dung ra, tôi có thể bổ nhỏ cái phần đó
ra, chia ra và để nó thực thi.
Đây khi mình click vào bên trong cái nội
dung nhá. Mọi người quay lại cái đoạn
này. Khi click vào nội dung [âm nhạc]
bên trong thì nó sẽ đi làm gì ạ? Nó nó
tự động nó phân tích ra từng file một,
từng từng nội dung chi tiết ở bên
[âm nhạc] trong á.
từng cái phần mà nãy mình
ờ đây
từng tab từng tab nó đi ra nó [âm nhạc]
viết rip rồi nó làm cái từng đầu mục một
á thì lúc này mọi người sẽ thấy là nó ra
không còn giống như ban đầu là đợi ngồi
chờ nó làm tốc độ nữa. Trong cái file
này Minh chỉ đâu đó mất khoảng chừng
nguyên một cái file này. Minh [âm nhạc]
chỉ mất khoảng có chưa tới đầy 5 phút.
Sau đó mình có yêu cầu nó thêm là cái gì
ạ? À chỉnh sửa lại cho nó đẹp. Tại lần
đầu tiên khi mình làm á là nó ra một cái
[âm nhạc] dạng như là file
file mà mình gửi cho mọi người đúng rồi.
Cái nội dung này nè là nó chưa được đẹp
như thế này. Cái cách [âm nhạc] trình
bày thôi còn nội dung mà mình không
chỉnh sửa gì thêm nó tự động nó làm xong
nó ra báo cáo luôn tự động ra cuối cùng
nó ra tới cái phần dưới luôn.
Mình chỉ yêu cầu nó mình hỏi nó thêm nè.
Đó giống như hồi nãy mình đang nói với
mọi người là khi mà mình có một bạn trợ
lý rồi và bạn trợ lý đấy mình muốn cho
bạn đó thông minh hơn, làm việc tối ưu
hơn để những lần sau khi [âm nhạc] gặp
lại tình thú đó bạn đó làm gì ạ? Bạn đó
chỉ cần là cái gì ạ? Thấy cái tình huống
này rồi là bạn đó bay vào là xử lý ngay.
Không có cần phải đi tư duy suy nghĩ rồi
buill làm cái gì đó mà nạp kiến thức mới
không cần. Mình chỉ cần nói cái đó thôi.
À nói những cái câu thông thường nha mọi
người. Nghĩa là với skill này thì
[âm nhạc] cái file PDF kể được số hay là
cái gì đấy cũng xử lý được mà không cần
bổ sung thêm gì nữa phải không? Đó mọi
người thấy không?
Đây là một cái mà mình đang cập nhật và
skill.
Đây nội dung [âm nhạc] skill quy trình
OCR ngoại ngữ dịch thuật đóng gói là cái
gì đó vân vân. Thì lúc này mình chỉ yêu
cầu đúng có [âm nhạc] một phần thôi là
trên này mình có nói với nó ở đây gì nè
đã được tích hợp AI Vision rồi đúng
không?
Nó trả lời cho mình. Sau đó mình mới hỏi
xác nhận lại nghĩa là với cái trường hợp
này lần sau là ừ mình không cần bổ sung
thêm gì nữa đúng hay không? Nó nói đúng
vậy hoàn toàn chính xác. Với phiên
[âm nhạc] bản được nâng cấp V1.1.1
1 hiện tại của cái này thì cái này làm
được cái gì? Đó, lần sau mình đưa file,
đưa dữ liệu lên nó sẽ không cần phải đi
à phân tích đọc lại những cái phần phức
tạp ở trên mà vừa từ giao diện. Cũng
giống như trường hợp này. [âm nhạc] Ở
đây mình nói nè nhưng tôi thấy cái trang
này à nhìn chưa có luxury, VIP, RAM vân
vân. Hãy thiết kế lại [âm nhạc] à theo
cái chuẩn là luxury thì lúc này nó tự
động nó nâng cấp lên nè. Đó, nó tự động
nâng cấp lên. Mình chẳng làm cần
[âm nhạc] làm gì hết. Rồi cuối cùng là
gì ạ? Mình lại tiếp tục mình nói là hãy
cập nhật cách thiết kế
đây mới nâng cấp vào skill giúp tôi
trong trường hợp dịch thuộc cho các tài
liệu khác ngôn ngữ. Thì lúc này cách
thiết kế này có tùy biến được hay không,
có áp dụng được hay không mình còn hỏi
xác nhận lại. Mình kêu cập nhật nhưng
mình vẫn yêu cầu nó xác nhận ha. Tôi đã
cập nhật cách thiết kế vân vân. Rồi lên
phiên bản 1.2 đây
lên phiên bản 1.2 mọi người thấy không
ạ? Có nghĩa là cuối cùng quay lại là cái
gì ạ? chatbot, trợ lý nó cũng tương tự
như là bên các nền tảng chptem nãy giờ
mình nói nhiều lần nhưng được cái ở trên
các nền tảng mà Aiz [âm nhạc]
hay là clock mà mọi người bắt đầu dùng
mà nghe nhiều ngoài ở bên ngoài chúng ta
chỉ cần nói và chúng ta cập nhật vào thì
như vậy là [âm nhạc]
chatbot của mình, trợ lý của mình nó mỗi
ngày nó càng ngày nó càng thông minh hơn
vậy thôi. Và thậm chí những cái loại
chatbot này chúng ta có thể mang để chia
sẻ nhé. Minh có thể share được cái phần
này cho mọi người. Chỉ cần bóc cái này
[âm nhạc] share là share file góc luôn
chứ không phải là share theo kiểu đường
link giống như checkbox thông thường nha
mọi người. Rồi
rồi cuối cùng là cái [âm nhạc] gì ạ?
Mình chỉ yêu cầu nó là deflow có nghĩa
là lên virtual. Cái này mọi người tạm
thời cũng chưa hình dung thì hiểu cơ bản
là đưa lên trên mạng, [âm nhạc] đưa lên
website rồi. Vậy thôi.
Ok. Thì đến đoạn này có một phần mình
tạm ngưng tí xíu. Thì ở đây có anh chị
nào
chưa hình dung chỗ này không? Mình bật
mic mình trao đổi thêm đi. Tại vì Minh
nói từ hồi nãy giờ từ khoảng 5:5 đến
đoạn này bây giờ là khoảng 6 gi rồi. Thì
có ai chưa hình dung
mình ngưng tí xíu là mình sẽ đi
[âm nhạc] qua một cái cây study của bạn
bạn
Ninh Huyền Trang nói về cái toán ha. Ok.
Rồi có ai đặt câu hỏi hay là có gì
không? Mình tạm ngưng để cho mọi người
load kịp chỗ phần này chứ để mình đi
nhanh quá mà với những bạn mới thì chưa
hình dung kịp.
Có ai đặt câu hỏi gì không? Hoàng ơi
>> không anh ạ. Có số cái em thì em cũng
nhắn và nhưng chưa thấy ai hỏi anh
[âm nhạc] phần này đâu. Em
>> sẽ đi tiếp về phần ví dụ về kế toán
được.
>> Ok. Rồi vậy thì mình đi qua ví dụ cho
phần kế toán đi. Bây giờ mình quay lại
cái bộ Megaf.
Ok. Cảm ơn anh Năng. Cảm ơn.
À
mình lại tiếp tục đi qua cái mẫu ban đầu
ha.
À lúc [âm nhạc] nãy mình có một cái bộ
Mega
cụ thể là ngành may mặt. Ok, bây giờ
mình sẽ đi qua đến cái phần đó là tạo
skill cho cái toán. Vậy thì Ninh Huyền
Trang ơi, em muốn tạo cái phần trợ lý
cho cái toán là phần cụ thể là phần gì
em có thể nói rõ hơn được không? Anh
chưa hình dung kế toán là trong đó nó
cũng có nhiều cái mãng công việc đầu
việc.
tạm thời nhá. Tạm thời mình anh cũng
chưa thấy em trả lời. Anh sẽ đi đi đại
đi.
À
nghiên cứu à ứng dụng
BDCA.
Ở đây có anh chị nào đã nghe được cái từ
BDCA này chưa ạ? Cho
toán.
Mình làm đại nhé. Mình đang mình đang
bất chợt với mọi người luôn. Cần ứng
dụng BDCA.
Ok.
Đó, có cái từ này thì chắc có lẽ là
những anh chị mà chúng ta đang làm việc
về cải tiến [âm nhạc] quy trình hay là
những cái đầu việc thì cái từ này là mọi
người sẽ nghe rất là nhiều ha. À tài
liệu ở trên mạng hay là YouTube thì nó
nói không thiếu á.
Chuẩn ISO. Đúng rồi. Ok. Vậy thì mình
thử đi mọi người.
À Hải Yến mình về mình nghiên cứu thêm
cái từ ha BDCI [âm nhạc] này sẽ hình
dung ra được đây là một cái chuẩn cao
ha. Nó sẽ cải tiến liên tục à nó đi theo
chuẩn chứ không phải nếu mà chỉ nói vài
ba từ thì cũng hơi không đủ thời gian.
Nhưng mình sẽ thử để cho ai nó hình dung
cái này nó ra như thế nào.
Còn kế toán thì nó phải đi sâu vào nữa
nha.
Rồi từ viết tắc của plan do check
[âm nhạc]
lập kế hoạch rồi thực thi rồi kiểm tra
rồi bắt đầu
BDCA
nhiệm vụ phân loại [âm nhạc] chiến lược
cộng tự động hóa phân loại chiến lược
cộng tự động hóa ứng dụng vòng BDCA để
vào bộ phận kế toán để cải tiến liên tục
quy trình [âm nhạc] giảm sai sót và tăng
hiệu suất giả định. Tại vì mình chưa nói
rõ giống như hồi nãy mình có nói với hỏi
bạn bạn bạn Ninh Huyền Trang đấy. Rồi
giả định như là phạm vi này là phần kế
toán [âm nhạc] doanh nghiệp vừa và nhỏ.
Mục tiêu BDC là cải tiến quy trình, đóng
sổ, đối soát, [âm nhạc] báo cáo, kiểm
soát chi phí. Người dùng là ai? Kế toán
trưởng, trưởng phòng [âm nhạc] kế toán.
Vấn đề điển hình bấm sổ chậm, sai sót
nhập liệu, công nợ tồn động, báo cáo
trễ, chu kỳ BDCA [âm nhạc] theo tháng
hoặc quý. Nếu bạn có vấn đề kế toán cụ
thể hơn, đóng sổ hay thuế hay lương công
nợ báo tôi để tin chỉnh xát hơn thì lúc
này nó sẽ cho ra ba phiên bản được không
cả nhà? Ba phiên bản firm. Frm một là
ngắn dùng để xác định rõ vấn đề cần BTCA
nhanh. Rồi mình bỏ qua from 2 dùng cho
hầu hết các trường hợp thực tế trong
phòng kế toán thì bạn là một chuyên
[âm nhạc] gia cải tiến quy trình kế toán
am hiểu cả hai lĩnh vực kế toán doanh
nghiệp luật thuế năm 2015 thông tư và
phương pháp cải tiến liên tục. Rồi đó là
câu thứ hai. [âm nhạc] À mình sẽ đi qua
mẫu thứ ba.
Mẫu from thứ hai nó nhiêu đây nè mọi
người. [âm nhạc] Rồi mẫu from thứ ba
dành cho kế toán trưởng muốn xây dựng hệ
thống BDJ toàn diện bền vững. Vai trò
bạn là kế toán trưởng kim chuyên gia hệ
thống kiểm soát lại bộ am hiểu chuẩn và
kế toán [âm nhạc] v thông tư 2004
ờ bộ tài chính luật kế toán kiểm soát
vân vân ngữ cảnh vân vân mình sẽ đọc
lướt v thôi phạm vi áp dụng BDC trên kế
toán bạn có thể ứng dụng BDC trên tám
lĩnh vực kế toán phổ biến bao gồm quy
trình đóng sổ kiểm soát chứng từ
[âm nhạc] đối sót công nợ đối soát tài
khoản vân vân kế tiếp quy trình VDCI
[âm nhạc]
plan do check up nha. Đ mọi người bắt
đầu hình dung nó sẽ nói nè. Plan nè.
[âm nhạc] Đây là quy trình nhé. Rồi B1,
B2, B3, B4 ờ đu [âm nhạc] tới phần triển
khai D1, D2, D3. Rồi tới Check đánh giá
kết quả ừ C1, [âm nhạc] C2, C3 rồi ắt
chuẩn hóa nâng cấp. Rồi nếu đạt mục tiêu
chuẩn hóa thì viết SOP hoàn chỉnh lưu
vào sổ tay.
À A2 là nếu chưa đạt điều chỉnh phân
tích nguyên nhân không đạt bước A3 là
quản lý rủi ro. Vậy thì đến đoạn này lúc
này nó output là output ra cái gì nè? Xử
lý ngoại lệ [âm nhạc] các basine đo
lường vân vân. Rồi mọi người thấy không?
Với một cái câu [âm nhạc] tưởng chừng cơ
bản thôi nhưng mình chạy với Mega Fr lúc
nãy của mình mọi người hình dung
[âm nhạc] chưa? Mình đã có thể ra một
cái mẫu cưng kỳ chi tiết nhưng nó nhiêu
đây là chưa đủ. Với mình là [âm nhạc]
chưa đủ. Tại sao mình nói là cần nó trở
thành một trợ lý mà. Vậy thì mình sẽ
copy cái phần này mình đưa vào yêu cầu
nó build một cái bạn [âm nhạc] trợ lý
cho mình nhé. Rồi giải quyết cụ thể nè.
H tiến quy trình đối với mẫu hai nè. Xây
dựng hệ thống kiểm soát nội bộ là mẫu ba
nè. Rồi, ở đây nó có nói thêm nếu muốn
tôi làm một BDCA cụ thể hơn, ví dụ
BDCA [ca hát]
cho quy trình đóng sổ cuối tháng hoặc là
BDCI giảm [âm nhạc]
sai sót nha. À liệu hóa đơn chỉ cần nói
vấn đề tôi sẽ triển khai ngay đúng cái
framework trên được không cả nhà? Đúng
chưa? Framework là cái nguyên một cái
module này, nguyên một cái bộ này.
Ờ Minh cũng chưa biết là cái này có phù
hợp với cả nhà hay không nhưng tạm thời
Minh thấy là có một số anh chị quan tâm
cái phần này. Minh sẽ [âm nhạc] share
cái này để mọi người có thể
share riêng cái phần này đi. Mọi người
có thể dùng
[hắng giọng]
ờ [âm nhạc] BBCA
lấy toán.
Rồi
mọi người có thể dùng cái này để đưa qua
chat GPT hoặc là Germin để tạo [âm nhạc]
chatbot nha. Nếu như anh chị làm về kế
toán được không ạ?
Hoặc là chỉnh sửa là nội dung cho phù
hợp. [âm nhạc] Rồi sau đó là dùng trên
cái chatbot chat GPT hay là ờ
để tạo chatbot được không cả nhà? Đây là
cái phần dành riêng cho bộ phận kế toán.
>> [âm nhạc]
>> Rồi vậy mình quay lại cái đoạn này.
Quay lại đoạn này tí xíu. Như vậy thì
đến đoạn này bắt đầu là chúng ta đã có
một cái mẫu Megaf dành cho kế toán. Rồi
mình sẽ lại tiếp tục quay sang bên đây.
Mình lại yêu cầu là đóng [âm nhạc] gói
ấm skill cho nội [âm nhạc] dung sau.
À sorry.
Rồi như vậy thì để mọi người hình dung
là đến cái buổi này đến đoạn này là
chúng ta sẽ build ra một cái bộ Megafm.
Từ Mega Frm đó mình sẽ đóng gói nó lại
thành một bạn trợ lý ở trên AI dành.
Những cái công cụ này còn gọi là skill
được không cả nhà? [âm nhạc] nó tự động
nó sẽ được thực thi với cái à cho những
cái lượng chat mới bất kỳ.
Ví dụ [âm nhạc] mình sẽ ví dụ tiếp một
cái case study khác.
Ờ
hôm trước những anh chị mà
những anh chị mà mà có đăng ký nhận cái
tài liệu về YouTube lên á thì đó cũng
chính là một dạng [âm nhạc] mình được ờ
đóng gói lại cái kỹ năng hoặc là những
cái kiến thức mà mình có đóng gói lại
thành một cái dạng trợ lý. Và ở đây mình
đặt cái tên là YouTube lên. Và lần sau
khi mà mình gọi tên nó thì chỉ cần là
cái gì ạ? đọc cái nội dung của đường
link YouTube này đi hay là mình gọi tên
nó bằng cách là suy được không cả nhà là
nó sẽ tự động
tiến hành phân tích cái video đó chứ
không cần mình phải tốn nhiều thời gian
cho cái việc là ngồi gõ câu lệnh cụ thể
mình sẽ đi vào một cái
bây giờ mở đại một cái
bây giờ nó [âm nhạc] quá nhiều nội dung
ok nội dung này đi của ông Alex Himoji
Mình cũng khá thích ông này ha.
Ok Hằng ơi.
Rồi mình sẽ copy đúng cái l đường link
này thôi nha mọi người. Đây [âm nhạc]
copy đúng cái này 100.000 đô trong năm
2026. Ok rồi mình p nó vào đây. Enter.
Vậy thì chúng ta đóng gói cuối cùng để
làm gì? Đóng gói những cái phần trợ lý
chatbot [âm nhạc] cuối cùng là để làm gì
ạ? Để cho những cái đầu việc mà chúng ta
sẽ gọi là nhanh gọn, đơn giản và không
cần mất nhiều thời gian được không ạ?
Đây là cái mục đích mà mình đang muốn
chia sẻ trong cái buổi sáng hôm nay để
mọi người thấy được [âm nhạc] cái tính
hiệu quả của công cụ antiravity hay mới
bây giờ.
Và nếu làm nhiều á chúng ta có thể tạo
ra thành một cái chuỗi nha. Thành một
cái chuỗi một cái workflow
hoàn chỉnh. Thì do cái thời gian
[âm nhạc] nó có hạn nên chúng ta không
có thể đi nhiều. Nhưng ít nhất là để cho
mọi người hình dung được chúng ta sẽ tạo
ra nhiều trợ lý khác nhau tại một thời
điểm. Nãy giờ Minh ngồi với mọi người,
Minh tạo ra đâu đó khoảng bốn trợ lý rồi
đúng không mọi người?
Đây nè
>> Minh ơi.
>> Minh ơi cho mình hỏi đi. [âm nhạc]
Có nghĩa là theo như Minh á là đầu tiên
là mình phải cần biết là mình muốn làm
cái gì trước rồi mình phải làm một cái
prom
>> mình lưu nó lại. Sau này á mình muốn làm
một cái tương tự như vậy á thì mình
[âm nhạc] chỉ cần đưa cái nội dung mình
c muốn vô là là mình gọi cái cái con ai
đó lên là nó sẽ tự động làm đúng như cái
cái mình mong muốn đúng không? Nó dạng
vậy đúng không Minh?
>> Đúng đúng.
>> Nhưng là có nghĩa là bắt đầu tiên là
phải tạo một cái prom trước
>> đúng
>> lưu lại cái prom đó
>> đúng không? Mình test cho nó làm ok
trước.
>> Dạ. Ok rồi cảm ơn Minh Hen
>> nghĩa là mình nói về cái tư duy tí xíu
nhé. [âm nhạc] Chỗ cái câu của chị mới
vừa hỏi rất là hay đó là đầu tiên mình
phải hiểu được, mình biết được là mình
muốn cái gì, cái này mình đang nói về
cái bài là đúng ra là nó thuộc [âm nhạc]
cũ rồi nhưng mà đầu tiên chúng ta phải
biết được là chúng ta khi dùng AI chúng
ta phải biết được là chúng ta muốn cái
gì. Còn nếu như mình dùng AI [âm nhạc]
kể cả là dùng công cụ AI agent mới bây
giờ là clot mà có siêu đẹp gì đó mọi
người đang quảng cáo trên thị trường
[âm nhạc] mọi người đang chạy theo nó
rất là là là nhiều đó nhưng mọi người
quên [âm nhạc] đi mất là mọi người đang
muốn cái gì khi làm với cái công cụ đó
thì nó cũng không ra được kết quả tốt.
Cho nên tại sao mà chính bản thân Minh
đến thời điểm này Minh chỉ dùng nó ở
dạng là gì? Minh chỉ dùng thử, Minh mua
nó và dùng thử. Mình cũng vẫn dùng Codex
của Codex là [âm nhạc] một phiên bản mở
rộng của CH GBT. Nó cũng là một dạng AI
mà mình cũng dùng chứ không phải là
không dùng nha mọi người. Tuy nhiên mình
dùng để mình có cái nhìn rõ hơn về giữa
các công cụ chứ không [âm nhạc] phải là
mình chạy theo công cụ được không cả
nhà? Là cái nhất. Nhưng quay lại cái bài
toán là mình hiểu mình đang muốn cái gì
và rõ ràng mình đang muốn những cái việc
đó, việc này việc kia nó cụ thể và nó rõ
ràng được liệt kê ra và mình vẫn dùng
nhiều nhất trên nền tảng antiravity đến
thời điểm hiện tại. Đến thời điểm hiện
tại [âm nhạc] là mình dùng gần như 80
90% công việc là trên antiravity này
thôi được không cả nhà? Trên này không
làm gì [âm nhạc] ngoài những cái công cụ
bên kia rất là ít được không cả nhà? Là
mình biết mình muốn cái gì sau đó mình
build những cái trợ lý đó. Lần sau mình
làm việc mình chỉ việc gọi tên nó lên.
Cho nên ở ngoài đó ngoài ngoài thị
[âm nhạc] trường mọi người thấy họ build
ra những cái công cụ rồi những cái này
cái kia rất là đẹp trên clock nhưng Minh
vẫn không chạy theo clock vì chi phí nó
trả cao rồi chi [âm nhạc] phí A BC các
thứ và mình cũng không có nhu cầu đến
cái mức độ là phải cao cấp như vậy được
không cả nhà? Rồi quay lại cái câu
chuyện của mình tí xíu. À đây là một cái
skill mà nó đọc cái dữ liệu trên nền
tảng YouTube được không cả nhà? Rồi mình
sẽ mở ra cho mọi người xem thử [âm nhạc]
nha. Xem thử co trong này nó có cái gì
hay mà tại sao ông Binh ông quảng cáo.
Và cái này thì đúng ra hôm trước có một
vài bạn đã hỏi rồi, [âm nhạc] đã đăng ký
nhận cái skill này luôn rồi. Rồi
[hắng giọng]
bình thường chúng ta lấy từ một cái
video
trên YouTube về chúng ta hay bỏ vào bên
trong notebook của em đúng không ạ? hoặc
là chúng [âm nhạc] ta bây giờ có một cái
công cụ là trực tiếp trên cái nền tảng
của YouTube nó sẽ có một cái phần đây là
trợ lý đặt câu hỏi luôn [âm nhạc] và
chúng ta bấm vào đây là chúng ta đã có
thể đặt được tóm tắt vấn đề hỏi nội dung
vân vân nó rất là tiện tuy nhiên mình
vẫn thích dùng chính cái công cụ riêng
nhất gì để chi ạ bóc tách cái phần nội
dung trang drip này ra sẽ rất là nhanh
và mình sẽ dùng [âm nhạc] được cho nhiều
mục đích khác nhau cụ thể không biết nói
ra thì mọi người có thể sẽ hơi mắc cười
Nhưng chính mình [âm nhạc] mình làm
video này xong, làm video này xong mình
up lên trên YouTube ví dụ vậy nhé.
[âm nhạc] Mình up lên trên YouTube và
cuối cùng thì sao ạ? Mình lại thảy ngược
cái đường link YouTube đó về bên trong
anti Gravity này. Nó sẽ tự động bóp tách
lấy [âm nhạc] cái trend rip, lấy ra
chính cái đoạn hội thoại mà của mình đã
nói với mọi người. Và nó phân tích được
cái đoạn này [âm nhạc] mình nói những
cái inside là gì, chia sẻ với mọi người
là gì. Sau đó nó tự động nó phân bổ và
nó phân tích lại là phần này của bạn
đúng chỗ nào, chưa đúng chỗ nào
[âm nhạc] để cải thiện nó đến mức độ đó
luôn mọi người. Đây là chính là cái phần
đang muốn làm để chi là để tự mình học
lại chính mình á và mình học từ những
video khác và [âm nhạc] mình học lại từ
chính mình. Nên mình làm ra cái phần này
từ cái ý tưởng của một bạn khác có gợi ý
về cách làm này cho nên mình làm lại cái
phần này rồi để mọi người hình dung. Vậy
thì [âm nhạc] lúc này á nó sau khi nó nó
làm ra nó sẽ có cái trend rip chi tiết
này ha. Mình không nói là đ phần tiếng
Anh mình lúc này mình muốn tương tác
mình thậm chí mình yêu cầu nè cho tôi
biết gì đó mình chỉ cần gõ nội dung vô
đây nhưng cái phần đó nó không quan
trọng cái đó là trend [âm nhạc] drip
thôi.
Đó quay lại cái vấn đề này thì khi mà
với cái phân tích cuối cùng đó cho mình
biết đây cái video này [âm nhạc] nói về
nội dung gì ngày phân tích là ngày mấy ở
cái bước này là nó sẽ ông nói về ông
Alex à Homji này là người ngủ trên sàn
phòng zin rồi bán công ty với giá 46
triệu đô lĩnh vực của ông này làm về cái
gì top 5 làm về cái gì nó tra cứu ra
từng chi tiết một [âm nhạc] à cái người
chủ kênh cái người speaker ở trong này
mọi người thấy không speaker nè chân
dung của người speaker được không ạ? Và
cái trường hợp thứ ba nữa là gì? Sau khi
nó phân tích ra cái chân dung của người
đó, điều khiến Homogy khác biệt là gì?
Thì chính cái này nó cũng phân tích
trong chính cái nội dung [âm nhạc] của
video mình ha. Nó phân tích trong chính
của mình. Rồi ở đây là cái gì nữa? Cái
tri thức ảnh, cái niềm tin ảnh mà ngày
hôm qua mình có share cơ bản mọi người
thấy á. Cuối cùng nó là cái gì vậy? Nó
cho mình biết là hiện tượng là câu code
của ổng nè. Đó và bối cảnh cụ thể là
20.000 gì đây nên [âm nhạc] chỗ này mình
hơi bị lỗi chức tả tí xíu. Niềm tin ẩn
của ổng là gì? Thu nhập cao không bằng
tiền mặt dày, tiêu sen không bằng ngủ
ngon. Đó chính là cái mà thông tin ổng
muốn truyền đạt ở trong cái nội dung cái
ý thứ nhất về cái Worldw 1. Cái ý thứ
[âm nhạc] hai, cái này mình tạm thử tóm
tắt cho mọi người thôi nha. Tại vì khá
là dài và nội dung chương trình của mình
nó [âm nhạc] cũng gần hết rồi. Thì nó sẽ
chi tiết hơn n đúng là khi ví dụ này à
sai là khi cái gì được không ạ? đã phân
tích và cái này đã áp dụng được cho Minh
áp dụng nè rõ luôn nè mọi người thấy mà
áp dụng được cho mình như thế nào ngay
tuần này [âm nhạc] xem lại sao kê ngân
hàng phân biệt chi tiêu cảm xúc nhà hàng
mới và chi tiêu đồng bẫy khóa học công
cụ đặt [âm nhạc] mục tiêu cụ thể là 100
triệu trong tài khoản trước khi nâng cấp
bất kỳ đó nó gợi ý cho mình nè mọi người
rồi được không [âm nhạc] thì như vậy mọi
người sẽ đi từng bước một ra tới cái áp
dụng được cái ý thứ hai là cái [âm nhạc]
gì áp dụng được ý thứ ba là cái gì ở cái
face 4 nó cho mình biết là cái gì nè?
Như vậy thì mọi người hình dung rõ không
ạ? Với nếu như mọi người làm nhiều với
công cụ [âm nhạc] này, chúng ta sẽ có
những trợ lý
có những trợ lý trợ lý đúng nghĩa luôn
đó. Chỉ cần đưa đường link vào yêu cầu
[âm nhạc] làm, gửi file vào yêu cầu thi
mà chúng ta không cần phải tốn nhiều
thời gian giống như những cái loại công
cụ AI trước đây. Chúng ta phải ngồi gõ
và chúng ta [âm nhạc] cũng có thể đưa
file nhưng nó lại thiếu sự linh động.
Không thể mở rộng, không thể cập nhật
hoặc là cập nhật được, mở rộng được
nhưng chúng ta lại mất thời gian nhiều
hơn cho cái việc cập nhật đó. Đúng không
ạ?
À Phúc Ân hả? Lát nữa anh gửi cho.
Ok. Đó thì cuối cùng là nó đi từng bước
như vậy. Thì lúc này mọi người thấy
không? Trong một video ngoài cái việc
mình nghe xong, mình thẩm thấu xong
[âm nhạc] thì lúc này mình cần phân tích
ra chi tiết được cái nội dung video đó
muốn truyền tải là cái [âm nhạc] gì và
nó mang được cái giá trị gì cho mình.
Đó là những cái phần mà kiến thức cuối
cùng mà nó cuối cùng nó phân [âm nhạc]
tích ra cho mình. Còn chi tiết thì một
speaker nữa nè. Đó nó nó nói riêng nó đề
cập riêng nữa nè.
Ok thì cái phần này là cái phần mà Minh
mong muốn chia sẻ trong buổi [âm nhạc]
hôm nay, trong sáng hôm nay và đến đoạn
này thì cũng chắc cũng đã đã hơn 6 gi
rồi. [âm nhạc] Thì Minh hy vọng rằng là
trong buổi này là cũng mang được một
phần nào đó cho mọi người cái cái cái
khái niệm về [âm nhạc] cái công cụ
antivity hỗ trợ được gì cho mọi người
so với cái công cụ Germini hay là chatt
được không cả nhà? Rồi cảm ơn cả nhà rất
là nhiều. Thì không biết [âm nhạc] a đến
đoạn này có anh chị nào có muốn đặt thêm
câu hỏi mình cứ bật mic đi cả nhà. Phúc
Ân thì từ sau cái buổi hôm trước bắt đầu
đến hôm nay mới lại tham gia anh em ngồi
với nhau nè
đúng không anh ơi?
Dạ đúng rồi anh. Cũng lâu quá [âm nhạc]
trời lâu luôn mới nay mới có thời gian
em vào trong zoom của anh. À mấy hôm
trước em cũng định vào trong cái buổi mà
[âm nhạc] ngày 4 56 ấy. Nhưng mà mấy
buổi đó là em đi công tác đi sớm à 5:30
sáng là đi rồi cho nên em không có vào
trong Zoom được.
>> Ok cảm ơn anh. Mới cách đây như một hai
hôm mà thấy Ân có đi tập huấn cho một
cái bên [ca hát] B gì
>> à. Dạ dạ đúng rồi. Bên học viện Bưu
Chính có em có đến [âm nhạc] tập huấn
cho bên cán bộ bên đó kỹ năng cũng cơ
bản thôi.
>> Ừ thấy hay quá. Thì đây cũng giới thiệu
với mọi người Ân cũng là một trong những
chuyên gia về AI cũng đi đào tạo về AI
mình theo mình biết như vậy.
>> Dạ.
>> À gặp anh Minh là múa rìu qua mắt thợ
thôi [tiếng cười]
>> cũng không dám. Thật ra chúng ta là
giống như những anh em mình ở đây là học
hỏi cùng nhau thôi. [âm nhạc]
>> Ừ. Dạ.
>> Ừ.
Ok. Rồi à. Không biết là ở đây mọi người
có ai có câu hỏi gì thêm không? Và chúng
ta sáng ngày mai sẽ có một cái
buổi zom nữa nha mọi người. Và tối ngày
mai
mình sẽ có một buổi nữa
tối ngày mai.
>> Đúng rồi. Gì anh Minh ơi?
Anh nghe
>> hôm qua em có đặt một cái câu lạnh nhờ
bên chỗ
bởi vì em vẫn chưa hiểu nhiều về cái
gravity này nên [âm nhạc] em có đặt câu
lạnh là em có một cái file
cái file thủ công của [âm nhạc]
của phiếu thu
phiếu chi tức là một cái file số quỷ và
có mẫu phiếu thu phiếu chi rồi
nhưng em không biết làm nh nào để có thể
>> lấy dữ liệu,
>> lấy dữ không phải lấy dữ liệu ạ mà là
lạnh cho nó xuất ra các cái phiếu thu
phiếu chi bởi vì
cái cái cái mà em đang làm là nó đang
làm thủ công nên em phải làm thủ công
ngoài. [âm nhạc] Em làm từ cái từ cái
cái việc thu chi của em thì em lên cái
sổ thu chi nhưng mà em chưa [âm nhạc]
xuất ra được phiếu thu phiếu chi.
Mà em đã có mẫu phiếu thu phiếu chi rồi.
Bây giờ từ trong cái nội dung sổ thu chi
đó thì nó xuất ra phiếu thu phiếu chi
cho em. Và em không biết làm như thế nào
để đưa cái file vào cho nó.
>> À cái này á thì đúng ra á là Yến đang đi
hơi vội. Thực ra là cái nền tảng của
mình á là về AI [âm nhạc] anti Gravity
này mình chưa hình dung hết cho nên sẽ
rất là ờ hơi mơ hồ. Mình dùng cái từ nó
hơi mở ồ là chữ [âm nhạc] ngay chỗ những
cái phần cách làm nè, cách đặt câu hỏi.
Nhưng mà Minh sẽ nói sơ lược nhé. Đầu
tiên là [âm nhạc] Yến phải hình dung
được là quy trình bình thường cái quy
trình của mình làm các bước đó như thế
nào. Bình thường á quy trình các bước
mình làm như thế nào? Mình phải rõ ra
làm rõ ra chỗ đó giúp mình. Ví dụ như
bước một cái cái cái cái
phiếu thu phiếu chi mà hồi nãy nó là
trên giấy hay là trên máy [âm nhạc] hay
là bản scan hay là bảng mà viết tay rồi
mình mới chụp hình rồi mình mới lại đưa
vào trong máy.
>> Điểm này tức là em đã có sổ thu sổ quỷ
rồi. Trong sổ quỷ nó sẽ thể hiện là
phiếu thu mã phiếu thu ngày tháng và
[âm nhạc] nội dung và số tiền. Được chưa
ạ? Rồi
>> rồi sau đó thì rồi thì em cũng có luôn
cái mẫu phiếu thu và mẫu phiếu chi
[âm nhạc] rồi.
>> Và bây giờ em đang rất là cần nó xuất ra
cho em một loạt phiếu thu phiếu chi đã
có nội dung, đã có số, đã có tiền.
>> Ừ.
>> Đấy
>> như vậy thì quay lại cái bài toán này
thôi. Nó đơn giản bạn. Vậy thì mình hình
dung hồi nãy cái bài toán quy trình của
mình bình thường mình làm như thế nào?
Mình đang liệt kê lại đi. Mình thống kê
>> bình thường bình thường là bình thường
là người ta sẽ làm
là nhập vào số.
Nếu như có phần mềm thì em sẽ nhập vào
phần mềm và sau đó in thôi. Nhưng mà bây
giờ bởi vì nó không có phần mềm thế nên
em sẽ nhập vào sổ quỷ bởi vì em làm lại
cái thao tác mà nó không phải là hàng
ngày nữa mà đây là cái lần gất rút mà em
phải làm.
>> Ừ.
>> Em làm một lần xong là mình xuất ngược
lại. Tức là người ta đi đi ngược thay vì
đi xuống em đi ngược ấy.
>> Ok cảm ơn.
>> Người ta sẽ có phiếu thu. Viết phiếu
thu, phiếu chi xong rồi vào số quỷ.
[âm nhạc] Đúng không? Viết hếu thu hếu
chi rồi vào số quỷ. Nhưng mà em vì nó đã
xảy ra rồi và em đang làm để mà để mà
thực hiện đóng gói lại hồ sơ cho nó đẹp
thì em đã có số quỷ rồi. Em có phiếu thu
phiếu chi rồi. Trước đây thì em vẫn quắc
lại xếp cái sổ quỷ này [âm nhạc] nó là
dạng file trên máy tính. File sale file
Excel hả?
>> Ok. Đó mình đang phân tích từng phần một
từ cái file Excel này là hiện tại em đã
yêu cầu là bóc tách ra chưa?
>> Bóc tách như thế nào anh nhở?
>> Nghĩa là mình đầu tiên mình phải hiểu
được [âm nhạc] là Gravity cách vận hành
của nó đã nó làm việc để hiểu được một
cái file kể cả cái file PDF nhá, file
hình ảnh nhá, file Word nè, [âm nhạc]
file Excel không phải là vào là Anti
Davity nó sẽ đọc được ngay. Mặc định
những cái file đó anti David không đọc
được. Excel nè. Đặc biệt cực kỳ khó.
Đuôi X LSX là cực kỳ khó. Vậy thì đầu
tiên nó cần phải mình phải cần phải cho
nó bóc tách. đưa
>> mình đưa cái dữ liệu đó vào mình đưa cái
dữ liệu hay đưa cái thư mục một file đầu
tiên để nó làm mẫu để nó làm mẫu và yêu
cầu nó là như thế này ví dụ như
[âm nhạc] hãy bóc tách nội dung
file Excel à này giúp tôi.
Đấy, chỉ một câu đơn giản thôi. Nó sẽ
bốc tách cái file này. Nó sẽ bốc tách
cái file này. Trong đó gồm có những cái
trường dữ liệu gì, những cái cột gì vân
vân và vân vân nó sẽ tự động nó build ra
những cái tool. Thì cái này nó đúng ra
nó đi chi tiết ở sau này mọi người sẽ
tìm hiểu sau. Nhưng đại khái là khi mình
dùng cái từ này sợ mọi người bị mơ hồ.
Có nghĩa là nó sẽ build ra những công cụ
như Python để nó bắt đầu để đọc dữ liệu
bên trong. Chính những cái công cụ Pyth
thành này chính là những cái tool mà lần
sau mình sẽ tái sử dụng nó. Thì đầu tiên
mình phải hiểu được là AI này nó đọc
được cái file đó như thế nào cái đã. Nó
bốc tách nội dung. Sau khi nó bốc tách
thì mình muốn nó làm cái gì tiếp? Bốc
tách ra được nội dung. Ok chưa ạ? Bốc
tách ra thì yêu cầu nó liệt kê theo dạng
gì? Dạng bảng hay là trình bày lại
[âm nhạc] dưới dạng nội dung là y như
ban đầu liệt kê ở trên này cho mình
nhưng mà trình bày theo dạng giống phải
[âm nhạc] góc để chi ạ. Mục đích là mình
xem thử nội dung đã ok chưa. Nếu chưa ok
thì mình lại tiếp tục tin chỉnh. điều
chỉnh dựa trên cái phần bóc tách ban
đầu. Tại vì AI á mặc định là mình nói
lại luôn AI này hay là tất cả loại AI nó
mặt nhiên nó không đọc được FEL đâu. Nó
vào nó phải build tool kể [âm nhạc] cả
chat GPT bây giờ mình có thể phel lên nó
cũng phải vào nếu mọi người để ý nó sẽ
tự động nó vào nó phân tích nó bóp tách
rồi nó đi ra những cái công cụ rất là
nhỏ trong đó gọi là Python để nó ờ đọc
được cái file Excel đó. [âm nhạc] Vậy
thì chị phải đi từ làm từng bước. Sau
khi có được cái phần nội dung bót tách
đó rồi mà nội dung mà mình thấy ok chưa
thì bắt đầu mình mới lấy yêu cầu nó tiếp
ở bước kế là lấy cái số liệu này đưa về
cái sổ sổ quỷ hay đưa về [âm nhạc] cái
gì mà nãy chị đang cần đó là đi theo cái
bước kế tiếp. Như vậy thì mình phải h
hình dung được là quy trình công việc cụ
thể. [âm nhạc] Tuy nhiên còn phải hiểu
được bản chất cái công cụ này nó làm
việc như thế nào nữa.
À ở đây có anh có bạn Phạm Hải có dùng
nói nè VPA để xuất ra phiếu chi phiếu
thu theo mẫu. Thì cái phần này mình thấy
chị có thể tham khảo thêm hoặc là mình
thì chính bản thân mình cũng không phải
là kế toán mình cũng mong rành mấy cái
này nhé. Nhưng mình có thể nhờ ai để
phân tích hỗ trợ thêm cái phần này được
nè.
Ok. Ờ thấy chị cũng [âm nhạc] đang có
điện thoại rồi. Ok. À xin phép mọi người
thì không biết là bây giờ cũng đã gần
6:30 rồi thì
chắc có lẽ sẽ có nhiều anh chị bắt đầu
mình chuẩn bị đi làm.
Thì chỗ phần chị Yến á chị làm thử lại
nha. Tại vì với cái phần mà cái sự kỳ
vọng á mình cũng nói lại cái chỗ này tí
xíu thì bổ sung thêm là mọi người khi
làm với một công cụ AI mới, đặc bên công
cụ AI nó có cái sự gọi là hoàn hảo và
mạnh như thế này. Mình dùng cái từ nó
mạnh thì nó hơi quá nhưng mà theo mình
là như [âm nhạc] vậy.
Mà mình kỳ vọng ngay một cái việc là vào
là giải quyết luôn được một cái bài toán
lớn là nó sẽ không thể nha mọi người nếu
như mình chưa hiểu bản chất của nó. Đó.
Vậy nên á là mọi người đừng đặt cái
[âm nhạc] sự kỳ vọng nó quá lớn rồi vào
cái cái bài toán mà mình đang cần giải
quyết như vậy sẽ làm cho nó cảm thấy
rằng ừ là tại sao ờ quảng cáo hay là tại
sao nói cái này có thể làm được hoặc là
tại sao Minh trình diễn thì được mà mọi
người làm không được không phải mà chúng
ta đang cần phải đi từng bước và khi
hiểu bản chất hiểu cách làm rồi hiểu quy
trình thì cái bài toán mình từ từ sẽ
được giải quyết
có thông tin từ sổ theo chuẩn
có biểu mẫu
à cái skill văn bản hành [âm nhạc] chính
này lúc trước là ân có [ca hát]
có có rồi nè.
Rồi coi như cái phần hôm nay á là chủ
yếu là mình đi với nhau để cho mọi người
hình dung được cái bài toán của antiity
có thể giải gì được cho mọi người thay
vì mình dùng trợ lý trên chat GBT cũng
được, [âm nhạc] Germini cũng được nhưng
hôm nay mình sẽ cung cấp thêm cho mọi
người cách nhìn cái rộng hơn là khả năng
của antipity nó [âm nhạc] có thể làm
được gì với chat những cái chat chatbot
hay là trợ lý riêng đó. Ok thì chắc có
lẽ đến đây cũng đã là 6:30 rồi và Minh
xin up buổi hôm nay và hẹn gặp mọi người
lại buổi [âm nhạc] sáng ngày mai cũng
như là tối ngày mai.
Thì với á là không biết đã dùng cái cái
antivirity 2.0 [âm nhạc] này chưa ha?
Nhưng tối ngày mai sẽ em có dùng rồi anh
>> à. Ok vậy tốt quá.
Lại có trải nghiệm rồi đúng không anh?
Dạ đúng rồi. Dạ em có trải nghiệm rồi.
[âm nhạc] Hôm trước em mới tải nâng cấp
lên.
>> Ok. Vậy là ok rồi. Thực ra là buổi tối
này không ngày mai á [âm nhạc] mình sẽ
nói sơ lược tối ngày mai mình sẽ tập
trung và cũng là cái công cụ antiravity
này. Nhưng nó [âm nhạc] đi khai thác về
cái việc là sự khác nhau giữa cái giao
diện cũ và giao diện mới. Và cái sức
mạnh của AI antiavity 2.0 này nó khác
biệt gì so với cái công cụ là Anti
Gravity [âm nhạc] Ider bản cũ.
Cái buổi tối ngày mai mình muốn tập
trung về cái vấn đề đó. Và nếu như
có thời gian mình sẽ trình diễn một số
cái trường hợp là tại sao mà gần đây
mình lại sử dụng song song hai công cụ
Anti Gravity. Tuy nhiên nếu như mà dùng
để build ra một sản phẩm, dùng để làm ra
một cái ứng dụng thì mình sẽ dùng ngay
cái Antia Gravity 2.0. Còn lại bên này
sẽ đi sửa lỗi hoặc là một số cái trường
hợp nào đó mình sẽ đưa qua đây. Thì ngày
mai buổi tối mình sẽ trình diễn. Mình sẽ
có một cái buổi Zoom. để trao đổi thêm
thì ân nếu mà tối mai hoặc là mọi người
ai có thời gian thì [âm nhạc] chúng ta
sẽ ngồi cùng nhau ha.
>> À dạ tối mai vô tư anh. Dạ hẹn gặp lại
anh Minh chắc là tối mai ạ.
>> Ok anh. Rồi cảm ơn cả nhà. Thì bây giờ
cũng đúng 6:30 rồi. [âm nhạc] Xin chào
cả nhà, hẹn gặp cả nhà và lại 5:00 sáng
mai và tối mai thì 8:00 ha.
>> Dạ. Rồi xin chào cả nhà luôn ạ. À chúc
cả nhà buổi sáng
tốt lành và công việc thuận lợi. Đ